j'ouvre tout de suite le second débat de
ce sens public vous le savez le plus
souvent possible on choisit de le
décaler volontairement de de l'actualité
du jour je vous propose de remonter huit
mois en arrière le 30 octobre Lula était
relu revenait d'une certaine façon
promesse d'un retour au pouvoir au
Brésil il était à ce moment-là
rapidement félicité partout les
dirigeants occidentaux Emmanuel Macron
en tête depuis ils sont nombreux à avoir
déchanté pourquoi le président brésilien
a-t-il tant de mal à tourner la page
bolsonaro veut-il s'affranchir peut-il
s'affranchir de ses puissants alliés
russes et chinois vendant débattre les
raisons de la déception avec Jérôme
Rabier
les attentes étaient grandes après
quatre années de présidence de Jair
bolsonaro mais les premiers mois de loup
la revenus à la tête du Brésil pour la
troisième fois sont plutôt décevants en
raison sur le plan intérieur d'un
système politique où il faut trouver de
nombreux alliés et donc faire des
concessions sur son programme l'exécutif
et en permanence soumis un chantage de
la part de la Chambre des députés pour
faire passer ses projets et a dû
détricoter une bonne partie de ce qu'il
de ce qu'il avait prévu de faire
notamment sur sur le plan de
l'environnement et des droits des
indigènes du Brésil mais la principale
déception c'est le positionnement
international du président brésilien en
avril dernier il place sur un pied
d'égalité Russie et Ukraine
le président Poutine ne prend pas
d'initiative de paix Zellen ski ne pas
d'initiative de paix l'Europe et les
États-Unis ont fini par contribuer à la
poursuite de cette guerre
une prise de position dénoncée aux
États-Unis en Europe qui protestent mais
finalement sur la scène intérieure peu
de Brésiliens sont choqués lola a
toujours refusé de s'aligner en
particulier sur les positions
américaines et le Brésil fait partie de
ce de cette grande partie du monde qui
se sent humiliés par l'histoire et qui
entend qui entend qui n'entend plus être
dans une position d'infériorité et tant
qu'on n'a pas compris ça
il n'y a que chez les occidentaux ils
naïveté des Occidentaux à penser que
Lula allait être reconnaissant pour le
soutien dont il a bénéficié au moment de
son de sa réélection et au moment de de
tentatives de coup d'État du 8 janvier
membre des briques ce groupe de pays
émergents qui réunit Bré sil Russie en
Chine et Afrique du Sud Lula défend
d'abord les intérêts du Brésil et peut
désormais se targuer d'être un des rares
dirigeants à être reçu en grande pompe
aussi bien à Pékin call Elysée quitte à
écorner son image en particulier en
Europe
je vous présente tout de suite mes
invités François Michel detourneau
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes directeur de
recherche au CNRS géographe spécialiste
du Brésil et de l'Amazonie brésilienne
Virgin jacoberge et Lavoué bonsoir
bonsoir et bienvenue à vous aussi vous
êtes journaliste aux écho et auteur de
ce livre au Brésil voyage au pays de
bolsonaro Paris aux éditions du Rocher
j'accueille Anthony Bellanger bonsoir
bienvenue journaliste spécialiste en
relation internationale éditorialiste
chez nos confrères de France Inter en
duplex avec nous également nos meilleurs
Feld qui correspondant du Monde à Rio
bienvenue à vous et auteur de ce livre
ce cauchemar brésilien paru chez Grasset
et mise à Polski évidemment est resté à
mes côtés François-Michel Letourneau
est-ce que vous employez ce mot de
déception vous quand vous allez Alizée
alors c'est il y a 8 mois qu'il a été
élu et ça fait 6 mois qu'il est au
pouvoir Lula oui nous d'abord je pense
qu'il est beaucoup trop tôt pour tirer
un bilan
Lula a fait des choses on le voit moins
à l'international parce qu'on est très
crispé sur la question de la guerre en
Ukraine et de son la posture qui ne nous
plaît pas autant qu'on aimerait mais il
y a des petites choses qui avancent et
surtout je pense qu'il faut faire il
faut regarder dans le rétroviseur et
regarder ce qui se passait en 2003 les 6
premiers mois de Loola n'ont pas été un
leader rose et c'est après que la
dynamique s'est lancé donc il est en
train de construire sa coalition c'est
difficile personne dit le contraire mais
je pense que il faut pas l'enterrer trop
vite évidemment Virginie Jacquot berger
l'avouer elle est si on parle si on
focus un peu sur les résultats
économiques il a été élu notamment sur
une promesse de de réduction de la
pauvreté ou de lutte contre la pauvreté
est-ce que est-ce que ces résultats sont
déjà là et est-ce qu'il a la marge de
manœuvre pour avancer dans dans ce cadre
là il ne l'a pas il n'a pas de marche de
manœuvre en fait c'est tout le problème
c'est qu'avec le poids Calc congrès en
fait on peut presque dire c'est un peu
exagéré parce que c'est difficile de
comparer les systèmes mais je pense que
faut de notre côté il faut aussi qu'on
comprenne que c'est un peu comme si on
il était en cohabitation quoi il faut
vraiment dire ça pour pour expliquer aux
gens qu'est-ce que c'est le régime
présidentiel au le poids de ce congrès
qui est resté conservateur et donc ça
fausse toute la donne j'aimerais quand
même revenir sur un point parce que
c'est vrai que la déception elle a
beaucoup souligné d'un point de vue de
politique internationale sur ses prises
de position effectivement sur le
conflits
quand même un point qui qui me semble
assez important depuis son mandat du
côté de la déception c'est que d'abord
je pense que déception elle est quand
même à géométrie variée parce que il a
été élu finalement c'est une courte
victoire en plus c'était un gouvernement
de coalition lui il a plutôt mis bar à
gauche parce que je pense que justement
comme il a du mal à manœuvrer avec le
Congrès bah en tout cas et surtout lui
alors ce qu'on voit quand même dans ce
positionnement très à gauche c'est aussi
quelqu'un qui n'a pas vraiment changé de
logiciel ce qui peut sans doute poser
problème et juste sur l'histoire de la
déception j'aimerais juste revenir sur
une chose qui me semble importante c'est
que en fait dans son début de mandat il
n'y a pas eu le phénomène ce qu'on dit
toujours les 100 jours vous voilà l'état
de grâce en revanche il a eu il a eu
quand même son moment où la terre
entière quand même était là pour le
soutenir on l'a vu tout le monde les
États-Unis tout le monde toutes les
démocraties c'est évidemment bien
évidemment moins les réactions à la
suite du 8 janvier les
Brasilia le choc psychologique d'une
démocratie attaquée et très honnêtement
pour avoir un peu enquêté sur ces
réseaux on est un peu dans le vraiment
de ces stress similaires à ce quand même
ce qui s'est passé à la prise du
Capitole donc toute cette image
politique internationale elle était
quand même on y reviendra sur l'Ukraine
et l'image internationale Anthony
Bellanger est-ce que effectivement ce
Lula 2022 il est très différent de celui
qui avait quitté le pouvoir en janvier
2011 il y a eu des épreuves il y a eu la
prison qui est passée par là est-ce que
et on parle de logiciel est-ce que
finalement il a pas eu un peu de mal à
se à se mettre au logiciel des années
2020 bah moi j'ai toujours dit il a été
pas très bien élu quand même il faut
l'imaginer il a une la différence entre
la voix entre bolsona et lui c'est à
peine 1,5% de la plus la plus faible
marge entre deux candidats à la
présidentielle il a 77 ans il est il ne
contrôle pas le Parlement l'a dit il est
largement conservateur et moi j'ai
toujours dit que c'était un candidat par
défaut c'est-à-dire qu'il avait besoin
probablement d'une revanche personnelle
mais effectivement il a pas changé de
logiciel l'homme qu'il était en 2000 en
dehors au milieu des années
2010 et le même qui arrive aujourd'hui
au pouvoir avec mais le monde a changé
entre temps et le monde a changé et
notamment dans la façon dont sur deux
points le premier est un et le point
économique c'est-à-dire que quand il a
quitté son premier mandat ou son
deuxième mandat c'était un monde qui a
envisageait effectivement de signer avec
le Brésil et le Mercosur c'était le
Brésil de l'Argentine c'est énorme
puissance agricoles de libre-échange
premièrement et deuxièmement le monde a
changé parce que les briques à l'époque
étaient les New Kids on the block
c'était ceux que tout le monde
accueillait quasiment avec commencer à
ajouter les
des uns et des autres pour dire ah bah
voilà c'est les nouveaux du alors
c'était dans le sujet Jérôme je rappelle
Brésil Russie Inde Chine Afrique du Sud
on pourrait faire le le détail de ces
pays-là et on verrait aujourd'hui que
une partie d'entre eux sont en faillite
une autre partie sont en guerre et une
troisième partie sont attentifs ou du
moins essaie et donc du coup le Brésil
ou là ne peut pas reprendre les mains la
même logorrhée qu'il avait à l'époque à
l'époque où il a quitté son deuxième
mandat Bruno meilleurs films
brésilienne tiens parce que nous c'est
vrai que vu d'ici avec un prisme très
occidental on parle de de déception que
disent les Brésiliens il y a pas eu
d'état de grâce nous disait Virginie
Jaco Hergé la voix est-ce que c'est vrai
de grâce mais c'était assez peu
prévisible assez peu possible cet état
de grâce vu la manière dont il a été élu
alors que disent les Brésiliens
aujourd'hui on a une opinion publique
qui est plutôt sur l'expectative on a
38% je crois des Brésiliens qui
approuvent l'action de loulas qui est
pas énorme surtout si on compare avec
les 85 % de popularité qu'il avait eu à
la fin de son second mandat cependant
38% c'est pas non plus infamant surtout
vu le niveau de polarisation qui existe
aujourd'hui au Brésil si moi c'est c'est
peu pour pour tirer un bilan et dire
exactement ce que les uns et les autres
pensent ce qu'on voit ce qu'on constate
c'est que il y a pas eu d'un animisme il
n'y a pas eu d'état de grâce après le 8
janvier après l'invasion des palettes de
brasiliables où là n'a pas su en
bénéficier je pense pour deux raisons la
première c'est que le rejet du Parti des
travailleurs et la peur de la gauche
d'aller des politiques de gauche c'est
encore très présente au Brésil après les
années bolsonaro et continue de l'être
et la deuxième c'est qu'il n'a pas
encore réussi à avoir de grands une
taille économique il est en train de
relancer tout un tas de programmes
sociaux il a une politique assez
prudente moi je dirais pas qu'il y a une
politique très à gauche du tout il
essaie de jouer sur les prix du pétrole
d'attirer des investissements étrangers
mais on n'a pas eu de choc économiques
liés à l'arrivée de là et c'était
d'ailleurs très prévisible en réalité
même si les équipes du Parti des
Travailleurs jouaient beaucoup sur le
pari de Lola aujourd'hui c'est d'avoir à
partir de l'an prochain une grosse
croissance économique une vraie reprise
en particulier de la consommation pour
pouvoir financer des programmes sociaux
et restaurer sa popularité celle de la
gauche François Michelet intervenir oui
non juste pour venir en contrepoint de
cette idée de la déception bon déjà le
pays n'a pas explosé quand tout là est
revenu au pouvoir comme vous dit qu'il a
été mal élu etc mais donc finalement il
y a une habilité derrière ça et le
deuxième point c'est que comme le disait
Bruno Marvel Lula est prudent il va
petit à petit il est en train de
négocier avec le Congrès impact qui va
lui permettre de regagner des marges de
manœuvre sur le plan budgétaire qui
parce que pour le moment en fait le
gouvernement bolsonaro excusez-moi de
l'expression mais mais la caisse et donc
du coup il a besoin de trouver ses
marges et après il pourra financer ses
problèmes sociaux et j'en reviens 2003
même situation d'accord
en fait par rapport à ces figures
politiques qui arrivent après des
populistes Joe Biden c'était pareil
finalement ils peuvent pas tout ils
peuvent pas tout parce que comme je
viens de le dire là on se méfie de la
gauche il y a eu des traces en fait qui
ont été laissées par bolsonaro ses
équipes les mentalités la façon de mener
la politique de la même façon que Trump
a laissé des traces et qu'on a un
jobiden qui est très protectionniste qui
a quand même des accents qui restent
proches en fait de sa politique donc on
attend comme un revirement comme si
naturellement le pays reprenait son
paysage politique d'avant et qu'il était
prêt à suivre ses orientations à mon
avis c'est beaucoup plus dur c'est des
attentes démesurées et peut-être qu'on
doit s'habituer justement à ce qui est
ces traces là parce qu'en Europe aussi
on a des nationalistes et des populistes
et peut-être qu'un jour il changeront et
ça reviendra pas naturellement comme
avant
plus qui reste fracturés qui l'ont été
par ces épisodes et qu'il leur reste
après on va on va je vais vous redonner
Apple dans un instant mais je voudrais
qu'on se concentre maintenant sur le
dossier ukrainien puisque c'est
évidemment l'un des dossiers importants
dans le bilan qu'on peut faire de des
six premiers mois de président Lula
sur ce dossier tiens je vous propose un
extrait d'une réaction de de du
président brésilien il était en visite
en Chine c'est quasiment au terme de
cette visite écouter ce qu'il dit des
États-Unis
les États-Unis doivent cesser
d'encourager la guerre et commencer à
parler de paix l'Union européenne doit
commencer à parler de paix afin de
convaincre Poutine et ski que la paix
est dans l'intérêt du monde entier
alors là aussi Virginie Jacob berger
l'avouer c'était illusoire d'imaginer
enfin autre chose si on reprend
l'histoire peut-être du Brésil mais
aussi du Parti des travailleurs de Lula
c'est un parti qui a alors j'allais dire
jamais je suis pas assez connaisseur de
l'histoire du Brésil pour être aussi
affirmier mais rarement été aligné sur
une position américaine ou atlantiste
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire puis
surtout lui c'est sa position au-delà du
Parti du Travail ailleurs la position de
Lula c'est ses convictions et il manque
pas de le rappeler
au-delà même on le voit aussi dans son
rapport avec la Chine voilà et surtout
avec la même la confrontation avec les
États-Unis
ceci étant je pense que quand même sur
le le conflit en Ukraine où il y a quand
même une grande déception internationale
c'est vrai aussi parce qu'il y avait
cette image après la prise d'assaut de
quand même un symbole qui est qui
représente quand même les valeurs
démocratiques voilà c'est pour ça aussi
que tout le monde les démocraties
ils pourraient être dans le camp des
démocraties peut-être que c'est le seul
aspect qui dans ce logiciel qui
effectivement est quand même un peu
ancien moi je rejoins tout à fait cette
idée qu'il y a un peu il essaie de
prolonger le dernier mandat et le monde
a changé entre-temps donc ça c'est un
vrai problème
d'un point de vue géopolitique mais
quand même il y a un point où peut-être
il a quand même évolué c'est qu'il sent
bien quand même que le monde est en
train de changer et notamment sur le
fait qu'il joue un peu sur ce rôle il
aimerait bien être un des piliers de ce
monde du Sud ce qu'on appelle
globalement et c'est très caricatural du
Sud et être sur tout le leader en
Amérique du Sud qui soutiennent comme ça
cette nouveau parce qu'on voit bien que
on est plus dans le monde totalement
bipolaire on était avant après sur ces
liens avec Poutine vous voyez bien que
d'ailleurs ça a été très honnêtement ça
coûte ça ça communication je pense
qu'elle a été quand même assez
catastrophique de par ses positions dès
le début du conflit ukrainien et après
de la même manière que bolsonaro était
venu avant le conflit voir Poutine parce
que une des raisons c'est quand même
l'agro-business c'est récupérer des
engrais des Russes donc il y a il y a
vraiment des vrais raisons au-delà du
marxisme de tout ce tout cet aspect
idéologique mais on sent bien que dans
son positionnement il a quand même été
c'est bien de dire le Brésil et
souverainiste il est quand même loin de
la neutralité il prend tout le temps
position et même si officielsieusement
officiellement c'est de la on dit c'est
le principe de souveraineté c'est de la
neutralité écouter je vois pas en quoi
c'est de la neutralité quand vous
reconnaissez pas ce qui a été le cas
plusieurs fois et depuis d'ailleurs son
discours a changé mais au départ il a
quand même inaccessé de faire des
déclarations en voyant les
responsabilités de Zelinski et bien sûr
et de Poutine sur la même ligne ce qui
est quand même un certain nombre de
raisons nous choquent est-ce qu'il y a
effectivement vous venez de l’évoquer
rapidement et je voudrais qu'on creuse
cet aspect une dimension économique
c'est-à-dire que est-ce que alors je
vais être un peu binaire mais est-ce que
Lula a plus besoin de la Chine ou de la
Russie que des États-Unis par exemple
oui alors je le dis pas exactement comme
ça bon la première chose c'est que quand
on dit la position de Lula nous choque
la question est qui est ce nous nous
l'Europe occidentale oui elle ne choque
ni les Chinois ni les Indiens ni la
plupart des pays africains qui ont
exactement la même donc en fait la
déception elle vient du fait que nous la
chanson dans un clan dans une position
morale inattaquable et il nous aimerions
que le Brésil nous rejoigne ils ont des
vues différentes sur ce que c'est vu
s'explique aussi par cette dimension
économique dont je parle elle s'explique
aussi par cette dimension économique
parce que le Brésil il est d'ailleurs on
en parlera de avec l'accord avec le
Mercosur mais le gros du commerce
brésilien aujourd'hui c'est la Chine et
donc du coup nous ne plaisons plus
suffisamment sur l'économie brésilienne
pour être en mesure soit d'exiger des
concessions diplomatiques soit des
concessions économiques ce qui est un
premier point mais pour revenir sur la
posture morale je suis désolé de revenir
toujours en 2003 mais en 2003 quand
l'Irak est envahi le Brésil dit
exactement la même chose que ce que Lula
dit aujourd'hui sur l'Ukraine sauf que
nous Français nous étions dans le même
camp voilà donc du coup ça nous choquait
beaucoup moins intéressant
le Brésil il faut jamais oublier que le
Brésil est un géant avec 200 millions
d'habitants et qui n'a plus l'intention
de se faire humilier il n'a plus
l'intention de se faire traiter soit par
le président Macron en lui disant il
faudrait peut-être que tu résoutres
résolves ton problème avec l'Amazonie ou
on se faisant claquer la porte à l'Union
européenne quand il s'agit de d'un
traité libre échange que le Brésil
essaye de négocier depuis 10 ans pour le
compte de ses adversaires donc c'est
exactement ce que de Bernard Bertrand a
dit ce grand géopoliticien expliquait
dans le temps des humiliés le temps est
venu de ces pays qui ont été humiliés
pendant tout le 20e siècle et qui n'ont
pas eu la parole et qui sentent
qu'aujourd'hui ils ont un moyen de
contrebalancer la première puissance
mondiale des États-Unis notamment
prenant langue avec la Russie et l'Inde
et la Chine et surtout plus question
pour eux de se faire donner la leçon par
des petits présidents à son quand on est
un petit président d'un pays de 60
millions d'habitants c'est-à-dire trois
fois moins peuplé que le Brésil et ben
on la ramène pas de tiens justement des
polyvette
les relations compliquées entre Emmanuel
Macron et Lou la diffusion à trouver le
président brésilien Lula les choses ont
plutôt bien commencé avec la joie
d'Emmanuel Macron qui avait été affiché
après la victoire de Lula en octobre
2022 face aux populistes bolsonaro en
témoigne la vidéo qu'il avait publié sur
son fil Twitter
comment ça va un Président
je dois te dire que
j'attendais avec beaucoup d'impatience
ce moment pour qu'on puisse relancer un
partenariat stratégique à la hauteur de
notre histoire et des défis qui sont
devant nous merci à toi et félicitations
pour cette élection c'est pour nous une
formidable nouvelle
arrêtons est très amical c'est presque
surjoué tutoiement félicitations tout en
triant des papiers ça c'est plus étrange
on voit comme deux amis qui se
retrouvent c'est vrai qu'on était plutôt
habitués à Jean-Luc Mélenchon dans ce
rôle avec le président Lula alors cet
ancien nouveau président il a quand même
des beaux projets côté environnement en
tout cas l'intention est là sur la lutte
contre la déforestation à l'opposé
évidemment de son prédécesseur et c'est
une lutte dans laquelle Emmanuel Macron
a décidé depuis un moment de s'inscrire
je sais pas si vous vous souvenez mais à
l'été 2019 il avait dit notre maison
brûle littéralement l'Amazonie le poumon
de notre planète qui produit 20% de
notre oxygène est en feu et peut-être
poser à côté de se défenseur des
écosystèmes et contre la déforestation
permettrait de valoriser sa propre
démarche écologique dans cette même
logique Emmanuel Macron avait reçu en
mai 2019 puis à nouveau le 4 juin
dernier le chef Raoni défenseur des trib
indigènes et de la forêt amazonienne au
Brésil Macron souhaiterait peut-être
aussi avoir le président brésilien de
son côté pour garder un oeil sur ces
fameux briques ce club très fermé Brésil
Russie en Chine Afrique du Sud qui
s'organise quand même au fil des années
dans cette nouvelle organisation
géopolitique que prend le monde avec la
guerre en Ukraine et bien sûr ben il
s'agit de discuter de négocier sur
l'Accord de libre-échange du Mercosur
dont on parlera un petit peu plus tard
le soutien que a porté Emmanuel Macron
évidemment au moment dont vous l'avez
vous en avez parlé de l'attaque du
palais présidentiel en janvier 2023 par
des partisans de bolsonaro mais
rapidement en effet la joie a fait place
à peut-être une déception dont on parle
une prudence aussi les signaux faibles
du président brésilien ressortent
davantage incapacité à assurer la
protection des peuples autochtones à
préserver l'Amazonie à une chambre des
députés qui restent fortement
conservatrices comme vous l'avez dit et
puis aussi sa volonté de garder cet axe
non aligné qui crispe l'Occident et les
propos dont vous avez parlé sur la
guerre en Ukraine qui choque énormément
donc les invitations entre Macron et lui
là se multiplient mais il y a beaucoup
plus de prudence et alors on va terminer
avec une communication qui se fait plus
discrète oui alors parce qu'il y avait
une invitation de Macron pour Lula au
sommet pour un nouveau pacte financier
mondial il y avait un déjeuner qui était
organisé en grande pompe au départ
c'était vraiment avec des photos des
images et puis très rapidement c'est
devenu beaucoup plus discret silence
radio en fait sur ce qui s'est
réellement dit pendant ce déjeuner il y
a d'autres rendez-vous qui sont prévus
le G20 qui est présidé par le Brésil et
organisé à Rio en novembre 2024 la COP
30 aussi en 2025 mais il faudra voir ce
qui est manuel Macron choisit est-ce que
ça sera une communication en grande
pompe ou alors plus discrètement pour
mener à bien la diplomatie mais à l'abri
des regards merci beaucoup Émilie
Anthony Bellanger ça être anecdotique
mais quand Lula est venu à Paris alors
il a fait Paris Rome il avait critiqué
la la nourriture de palais de de palais
présidentiel c'est c'est pas seulement
enfin il y a aussi un sens politique
parce que il veut c'est opposé de monde
opposé lui qui est un pet qui est un
syndicaliste qui a péné pour arriver au
pouvoir qui a été élu trois fois qui a
fait de la prison qui a 77 ans un vieux
brise-card de la politique et surtout
son pays qui est un pays agricole une
énorme exportation des normes
d'exploitation agricole pays de l'avenir
est-ce que disait de Gaulle le Brésil
est un pays d'avenir il le restera donc
et c'est justement ça qu'il peut
reprocher et qu'il reproche et ça de
manière assez pays européens qui pètent
dans la soie qui sont aristocratique qui
refusent absolument de comprendre ce
qu'est le Brésil de quel de ce que sont
les puissances de demain c'est ça qu'il
dit quand il dit on mange mal en France
et en Italie et d'ailleurs illumini un
petit peu au passage Emmanuel Macron en
leur envoyant dos à dos avec mes Georgia
Meloni en sachant que ça ne que ça le
que ça le que ça risque de bien agacer
évidemment évidemment ça agacer
pour des raisons d'ordre alphabétique
protocolaire voilà c'est c'est aussi
simple que ça comment elles sont
interprétées analyser commenter au
Brésil c'est ce duo je sais pas
d'ailleurs si les Brésiliens en parlent
beaucoup ce duo Macron là
non non les Brésiliens on parle pas
beaucoup le Brésil c'est un pays ça a
été rappelé de plus de 200 millions
d'habitants c'est un pays gigantesque
mais c'est aussi un pays extrêmement
isolé non seulement l'hémisphère sud en
Amérique latine géographiquement mais
c'est un pays qui pense assez peu ça
place dans le monde en réalité c'est
pensé par quelques géopoliticiens et
quelques chercheurs de l'élite mais le
peuple en général
a pas d'intérêt particulier un peu comme
aux États-Unis à penser le monde en
général ce qui est sûr c'est que ces
images de Lula elles sont très exploite
du pouvoir et du Parti des Travailleurs
justement pour vendre un Brésil de
retour c'est ce que dit tout le temps là
de retour sur la scène internationale
qui retrouve son rang à l'étranger
Macron en de manière spécifique au
Brésil Emmanuel Macron il a pas une
image excellente en particulier à cause
de ces attaques contre
2019 n'ont pas tant pour avoir
cette bagarrer avec bolsonaro qui est
loin d'être aimé de tout les Brésiliens
mais plutôt pour ce qui a été ressenti
comme une attaque contre la souveraineté
brésilienne en Amazonie et à l'époque
même la gauche du Parti des travailleurs
et jusqu'à là que j'avais interviewé à
l'époque disait oui on protège
l'Amazonie mais c'est les Brésiliens qui
protègent l'Amazonie c'est pas un
patrimoine mondial de l'humanité ils
étaient très gênés par par Emmanuel
Macron à l'époque alors évidemment Lula
a une énorme gratitude envers Emmanuel
Macron puisqu'il l'avait reçu à l'Élysée
en novembre 2021 presque un an avant
l'élection présidentielle alors que Lula
a commencé tout juste à rentrer en
campagne il a des reçu avec tapis rouge
Garde Républicaine l'entretien de plus
d'une heure je crois et ça avait
énormément été exploité par les équipes
du Parti des Travailleurs pendant la
campagne il a une grande gratitude
envers Emmanuel Macron mais on avait
aussi que leur position pouvait diverger
sur le traité de libre-échange du
mercossoul ou sur l'Amazonie et bien sûr
sur sur la guerre en Ukraine alors ce
une seule Lula qui sillonne l'Europe et
le monde on va voir plusieurs images
comme ça de de voyage
diplomatiques de du président brésilien
en Europe en France en Italie on va
aller voir voilà ce défiler pendant
quelques secondes avec quand même un
élément important François Michel
letourne c'est de dire que il y a un
isolement qui existait sous bolsonaro
qui a été en partie rompue ça c'est un
premier élément qui est enfin quand on
le thème de notre débat c'est la
déception là avec un point
d'interrogation là c'est plutôt dans la
colonne plus quand même on peut pas dire
le contraire non tout à fait il a vu
plutôt un grand succès alors après
c'était pas très difficile parce que
déjà son prédécesseur était franchement
rustre et en plus il a tout fait pour
isoler le Brésil donc il suffisait
d'apparaître au balcon et tout à coup
tout le monde est content mais je
voulais revenir sur l'histoire de la
critique de la nourriture de palais je
pense que c'est beaucoup plus quelque
chose à vocation interne parce que
justement tous ces voyages commencent à
être critiqués au Brésil on commence à
dire à mes finalement tu t'occupes de
nous quoi il s'habituent aux avions ils
savent que le luxe donc c'est une
manière de revenir dans la politique
nationale en disant non non je me fais
ça que par obligation parce que voilà et
voilà et pour il est moqué d'ailleurs ça
fait partie de sur le le le la
multiplication des voyages et des
déplacements international a commencé à
l'entendre sa participation à la Coop a
été critiqué aussi parce qu'il a
embarqué dans le chat d'un entrepreneur
privé enfin bon il y a eu plusieurs
choses comme ça et la deuxième chose sur
la question de la protection de
l'Amazonie effectivement les
déclarations de Macron 2019 qui avait
beaucoup irrité y compris le président
Lula qui enfin à l'époque le prisonnier
Lula qui avait déclaré que à ce
compte-là la NASA aussi est un bien
public mondial et qu'il souhaitait que
les États-Unis la donnent à l'ensemble
de la planète voilà donc c'est pour
donner l'image que les Brésiliens ont de
cette histoire alors on a un mot j'ai
juste pour dire que Emmanuel Macron j'en
suis absolument convaincu n'a pas pu
s'empêcher de lui faire le son
c'est-à-dire que c'est grosso modo c'est
pas il est il apprend le moment rendu de
grand service à Loula qui a dessus qui a
su le lui savoir gré mais je me je ne
m'imagine pas un instant qu'au moment de
repas il lui a pas dit il lui a pas fait
la leçon sur l'Amazonie ou la sonde sur
autre chose sans se rendre compte que un
rapport personnel ne signifie pas il n'y
a rien de personnel dans la diplomatie
mondiale rien de personnel il va falloir
qu'un jour quelqu'un ne lui explique à
Emmanuel Macron rien de personnel et
sinon on finit toujours par se fâcher
avec les gens avec lesquels on pense
avoir d'excellentes relations alors vous
avez les uns et les autres faire
référence au Mercosur on va tout de
suite en savoir plus grâce à Audrey beta
c'est rebonsoir Audrey l'élection de
Lula est là elle a relancé on va dire
cet accord entre l'Union européenne et
les pays de l'Amérique du Sud à corps
qui avait été bloqué par l'arrivée de
bolsonaro au pouvoir essentiellement
pour des raisons écologiques bon on est
six mois après le retour de de Lula au
pouvoir est-ce que ça a vraiment avancé
on en est où et bien déjà il faut
expliquer qu'on parle d'un serpent de
mer avec un accord qui est dans les
cartons depuis les années tenez-vous
bien 90 un projet d'accord économique
donc entre l'Union Européenne
l'Argentine le Brésil le Paraguay
l'Uruguay et le Venezuela je ne cite que
les membres permanents il avait été
relancé
en 2019 avant d'être bloqué par la
France notamment raison invoquer à la
déforestation les déforestations
massives en Amazonie soudoyer bolsonaro
si l'accord a été relancé vous l'avez
dit aussi parce que Lula a engagé la
parole présidentielle en promettant zéro
déforestation d'ici 2030 autre point
positif Lula veut cet accord écouter
par le fait que le président brésilien
et bien est en train de prendre la
présidence pour six mois du Mercosur et
donc tout ça crée un moment une
opportunité pour avancer dans ce dossier
qui effectivement bloqué depuis 2019
sauf que voilà entre 2019 et la reprise
des négociations l'Union européenne a
adopté plusieurs lois pour renforcer la
protection de l'environnement elle
impose à ses partenaires commerciaux de
nouvelles contraintes et notamment au
pays du mercosurcy-laccord était signé
contrainte qu'ils ne sont pas prêts à
accepter en gros et pour schématiser
l'Union européenne et demande au pays
sud-américains désormais de produire
dans le cadre du respect des objectifs
de l'accord de Paris mais de manière
contraignante c'est à dire que si c'est
pas le cas il y a des disponible de
sanctions qui sera appliquées contre les
pays sud-américains si ce qu'il faisait
ne permettait pas de répondre aux
objectifs de l'accord de Paris or les
pays
sud-américain et en particulier Brésil
réfute cet argument rappelant que
l'accord de Paris est non contraignant
et puis là joue sa partition en
défendant ses intérêts et ceux de ses
alliés justement sur le fond il juge
pour l'instant que cet accord est
déséquilibré au détriment des pays
d'Amérique du Sud et en s'étant partie
pour cela que ça coince dernière
intervention globalement il est perçu
comme asymétrique ce mot est très
important d'abord parce qu'il considère
c'est un accord qui ne laisse au pays
sud-américain que la possibilité de
continuer à exporter des matières
premières et des ressources naturelles à
faible valeur ajoutée sur les marchés
européens et la négociation de quota
d'exportation plus ou moins importante
pour eux ne suffit pas ça ne suffit pas
à faire un bon accord alors Lula a
annoncé qu'il ferait des propositions
dans les semaines à venir et puis pour
être tout à fait exhaustif il faut aussi
rappeler qu'il y a certains pays de
l'Union européenne qui ne sont pas en
faveur de cet accord et c'est peut-être
aussi pour ça que ça coince évidemment
merci beaucoup Audrey veetas pour pour
tous ces détails Virginie jacoberger la
voie c'est vrai que
parfois on a le sentiment que personne
n'en veut vraiment de cet accord comment
vous l'analysez surtout peut-être pas la
France quand même un rôle particulier
avec notre agriculture et quand même cet
accord alors on comprend aussi les
positions brésiliennes depuis le temps
effectivement c'est un vrai serpent de
merde je pense que le seul un des seuls
mini c'est justement celle-so à morine
qui est maintenant un peu le le
l'hémisphère spécial pour les relations
internationales de Lula qui est vraiment
a été précédemment ministère de ministre
des Affaires étrangères et qui a connu
le le commencement mais franchement à
quel accord on peut comparer
cet accord Union européenne merco sourd
parce que c'est vraiment on en finit
plus quoi c'est c'est c'est c'est assez
phénoménal après on sait la rupture
bolsonaro on la comprend très bien c'est
vrai que après cette rupture on comprend
aussi que normalement le processus
devait être lancé et après dans son
contenu on voit bien que les positions
sont quand même presque IR quand même un
vrai problème sur le fond c'est quand
même deux modèles complètement enfin si
on prend par exemple schématiquement
quand même on peut dire que quand Lula
est venu je pense à Paris avec cette
idée d'obtenir parce qu'il y a quand
même un peu ça en coulisse d'obtenir de
la part de Emmanuel Macron en se disant
écoutez nous notre premier de nos
premiers clients c'est la Chine il y a
nos amis russes il y a la Chine
maintenant l'Europe faites quelque chose
pour justement dans ce monde qui change
dans ce Sud qui devient de plus
important pour jouer notre jeu d'une
certaine manière il est aussi venu avec
cet accord Europe Mercosur avec un
caillou un peu dans la chaussure parce
qu'il est évident que d'un point de vue
européen ça pose un certain nombre de
problèmes et en premier lieu justement à
la France de par la portance de son
agriculture est un modèle qu'on entend
préserver mais vous disiez l'un et
l'autre que le logiciel de de Lula était
peut-être un peu daté mais est-ce que le
logiciel de cet accord est pas daté lui
aussi c'est
est-ce que c'est pas le libre-échange
dont une grande partie de de
pas tous là encore ne veut plus le
dernier pays à ces trucs glissé entre
les mailles du fil et c'est le Canada et
regarder un peu les réactions qu'on a
qu'on a le Canada c'est 38 millions
d'habitants c'est peut-être le deuxième
pays le plus important au monde mais
c'est dans une maison habitants et c'est
à peine sur la partition Sud donc c'est
le problème du Canada de poser pas du
tout le problème que poserait à
l'agriculture européenne le Brésil
l'Argentine l'Uruguay le Paraguay c'est
on a là on a affaire à des géants
mondiaux on importe déjà énormément de
soja de lors de leur et des soja OGM qui
pose un véritablement des soucis en plus
la la grande période des accords de
libre-échange qui était celle des années
80-90 2000 c'est terminé ses fracassé
sur sur d'une salle une certaine façon
encore en plus sur la guerre en Ukraine
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a un monde qui a
changé à ce moment-là et probablement
pour les accords de la givrechange même
beaucoup avant il est impossible pour la
France qui n'est même pas la première
agriculture d'Europe déjà il va sinon
c'est que ce pays qui se veut agricole
n'est plus la première exportateur de de
produits agricole en Europe c'est
l'Allemagne c'est qui lui taille des
croupirs sur l'état sur l'état de sur
l'état de produits et donc c'est ce pays
qui va bloquer mais pour une bonne
raison qui est que ces accords de
libre-échange surtout à cette magnitude
ne passe plus auprès des opinions
politiques auprès des opinions publiques
votre avis là-dessus est-ce que est-ce
que à l'air de la relocalisation de la
souveraineté alimentaire enfin voilà ces
thèmes qui pas seulement dans la dans la
société et l'opinion française prennent
de plus en plus de place est-ce qu'on
peut encore imaginer signer un traité de
libre-échange comme celui-là la question
se pose mais je pense surtout que on
parlait de logiciels daté je pense que
ça c'est l'Union européenne qui n'a pas
le bon logiciel et qui est daté c'est à
dire que nous pensons encore que nous le
savons le centre du monde et que notre
puissance économique fait que tout le
monde va nous donner les concessions que
nous souhaitons et que nous pouvons
imposer aux gens des conditions des
punitions etc le Brésil a changé de
logiciel nous dit ben maintenant je fais
40 % de mon commerce avec la Chine donc
si c'est pour exporter des productions
agricole à bas coût ils achètent la
battre bien en plus ils me pose aucune
condition donc voilà donc proposez-nous
quelque chose de mieux et effectivement
nous voyons que nous ne sommes pas dans
ce moment capables de proposer au Brésil
autre chose notamment un véritable
accord sur non pas l'agriculture parce
que ce serait peut-être pas le centre du
sujet mais ce serait l'industrie que le
Brésil veut s'industrialiser nous avons
des produits industriels il y a des
questions de service voilà c'est sûr ces
points là peut-être qu'on pourrait
discuter avec le Brésil on s'aperçoit
qu'on ne le fait pas
complètement d'accord parce que l'Union
européenne a quand même gober pas mal
d'accord et de choses qui étaient
défavorables sans imposer je pense à la
Chine notamment en ayant peur à chaque
fois des représailles sur le vin
français à chaque fois j'ai l'impression
moi ça me rassure plutôt que justement
peut-être parce que ces contextuel et
que cet accord est plus du tout
imaginable par rapport au temps qui
court de besoin de recolocalisation de
souveraineté alimentaire agricoles tout
ce qui suit la crise covid la crise en
Ukraine moi ça me rassure plutôt que
l'Union européenne se réveille un peu et
n'accepte pas tout c'est vrai que c'est
un gros pays une grosse ça représente
beaucoup mais c'est quand même assez
rassurant que elle reste pas l'enfant un
peu
idiot qui se laisse avoir moi je trouve
que oui ça me rassure peut-être à propos
de cet après-midi sur le Brésil premier
pays mondial utilisateur de pesticides
donc quand même c'est un modèle de
dingue bien sûr mais c'est quand même un
modèle agriculture on est aussi de ce
point de vue là
or valeur ni contrôle alors il y a le
vrai problème et là vous avez raison de
le souligner c'est que l'Europe est
affaiblie c'est à dire grâce grosso modo
notamment avec encore une fois cette
guerre en Ukraine et d'autres soucis
l'Europe est affaiblie elle est
affaiblie par les nationalistes mais
l'État fabli sur d'autres
interprétations d'elle-même qui sont qui
prévaut qui prévalent en ce moment dans
certains nombre de pays elle est
affaiblie aussi au moment de négocier
avec un Brésil qui pour le coup je pense
qu'il n'a pas changé vraiment de
logiciel que d'abord ils veulent
exporter vers l'Europe s'il le peuvent
leurs produits agricoles parce qu'ils
l'ont toujours fait c'est c'est ce que
le Brésil a d'abord a proposé maintenant
effectivement il faut discuter industrie
et services et les personnes ne le fait
pas mais ce qui le vrai problème c'est
vraiment l'affaiblissement de l'Europe
allez on va parler de l'Amazonie il nous
reste quoi 7-8 minutes dans ce débat là
aussi pour essayer de faire un bilan de
l'action de de Lula sur la lutte contre
la déforestation alors ce premier
chiffre on pourra le remettre en
question un peu plus tard mais je vous
donne le ce chiffre 356 km² de forêt
amazonienne détruit au Brésil en mars
2023 si on compare un an auparavant ça
fait une augmentation de 14% qui était
la dernière année de de bolsonaro qui se
proclamait s'autoproclamer capitaine
tronçonneuse je le rappelle Lula
pourtant il affirme que son plan
d'action va inverser la tendance en
l'écoute
nous venons de relancer le plan d'action
et de lutte contre la déforestation en
Amazonie légale qui dans sa version
précédente au cours de mes deux premiers
mandats a produit la plus grande
réduction des taux de déforestation en
Amazonie de toute son histoire nous
relançons la création de zone protégées
de parcs et de réserve
François est-ce que la tendance est en
train de s'inverser c'est-à-dire est-ce
que depuis le début de cette de cette
année 2023 on commence à assister à
cette invention de tendance c'est en
Amazonie je suis désolé mais ça va être
trop tôt c'est trop tôt pour le dire
alors déjà parce que l'indicateur qui
est utilisé cette indicateur mensuel
n'est qu'un indicateur très indicatif et
très approximatif qui dépend du climat
notamment parce qu'on brûle plus quand
il fait plus sec et la saison ça je peux
manger peut changer de place donc il va
falloir attendre septembre pour qu'on
ait les le compte sur l'année qui est
comparable d'une année sur l'autre et
déjà là on y va un peu plus clair la
deuxième chose je suis désolé de revenir
toujours 20 ans mais les années les plus
fortes de déforestation au Brésil c'est
2003 2004
faire tourner un paquebot il faut du
temps donc il faudra un deux trois ans à
Loula pour récupérer et le dernier point
qui est important là-dessus c'est que la
déforestation sous bonne sonnaro a
augmenté considérablement mais elle est
elle n'a jamais été au son plus fort que
le tiers ou un peu plus 40 % de ce
qu'elle a été au plus fort du début du
gouvernement Lula donc voilà donc les
choses sont un petit peu plus complexes
quand on regarde les chiffres que ce
qu'on peut imaginer au départ maintenant
le fait est que le plan qu'il avait
lancé en 2003 2004 et qui a duré pendant
8 ans c'est surtout ça qui c'est son
succès à amené une énorme réduction de
la déforestation on peut espérer qu'ils
prennent le même chemin même si c'est un
dernier point le gouverneur Lula vient
de se faire réorganiser son gouvernement
par l'Assemblée nationale puisque ces
insomnisations qui votent l'organisation
du gouvernement et ils ont légèrement
écorné les pouvoirs du ministère de
l'Environnement juste pour expliquer
écoutez bien on n'est pas complètement
d'accord donc ceci va se négocier ocier
Bruno maire localement
dans cette région de l'Amazonie qui
détient le pouvoir et quelle est la
marge de manœuvre d'un loup là d'un
président
bon il y a des marges de manœuvre parce
que la destruction a tellement augmenté
sous gère bolsonaro que en remettant en
place des politiques coercitives des
amendes une des agences de protection de
la nature tout simplement des gens
compétents à la tête du ministère de
l'Environnement on peut avoir une
réduction de la déforestation c'est
effectivement beaucoup trop tôt pour
affirmer quoi que ce soit par rapport à
la protection de l'Amazonie sous la mais
je crois que sur les cinq premiers mois
de l'année on a quand même eu une
réduction d'à peu près 30% de la
déforestation par rapport au même mois
l'an dernier alors personne ne dit que
c'est soutenable sur l'ensemble de
l'année la saison sèche vient à peine de
commencer mais c'est quand même un
premier signal positif moi je pense
qu'il faut aussi être attentif à
plusieurs facteurs et notamment à
plusieurs biomes parce qu'il n'y a pas
que l'Amazonie qui est menacé au Brésil
il y a aussi d'autres
types de végétation et notamment le
serhat qui est une savane qui recouvre
25% du Brésil qui est une immense source
de biodiversité et hydraulique également
et qui aujourd'hui subit une destruction
sans précédent même sous les années
bolsonaro quand vous interrogez les
agences de protection de l'environnement
et des spécialistes du sujet et vous
explique que Lula et l'agronégoce savent
qui doit faire des efforts sur
l'Amazonie pour l'image internationale
et la vente des produits brésiliens mais
qu'en échange une destruction du serrage
de qui arrive souvent même
majoritairement dans des états gouvernés
par des personnalités de gauche voire
des personnalités du Parti des
travailleurs au Brésil là on peut y
aller et là c'est autorisé et c'est ce
qu'on perçoit je crois qu'au mois de mai
la déforestation de la destruction du
serrade a augmenté de 80% ce qui s'est
déjà vu même sous j'ai un bol sous
marron donc il faudra quand on fera le
bilan de Luna et encore une fois c'est
beaucoup trop tôt il faudra voir
l'ensemble de la galerie et notamment
Lula a pu un certain nombre de projets
d'infrastructures en ce moment au Brésil
qui sont extrêmement nocifs pour
l'environnement des forages pétroliers
dans le l'embouchure de l'Amazone ou
encore une ligne de chemin de fer qui
traverserait le matos pour permettre
d'exporter plus facilement les cultures
du soja donc il faut aussi faire
attention à l'ensemble des planètes
focalisé que vous avez
élargi le curseur il faut jamais oublier
que là c'est un peu un syndicaliste et
j'étais c'est à dire proculé clair pro
industrie programmé il faut il faut
l'avoir en tête c'est un syndicaliste il
aime l'industrie là et il veut que son
pays se développe par ailleurs c'est
très bien d'avoir fait la différence
entre ces Radoux et et
Amazonie Amazonie parce qu'effectivement
c'est l'ensemble qui doit être considéré
comme étant comme étant un problème
écologique merci beaucoup on termine
là-dessus merci à tous d'avoir participé
à ce à ce débat je rappelle le titre de
vos livres Virginie Jacob berger
l'avouer Brésil voyage au pays de
bolsonaro paru aux éditions du Rocher et
Bruno Mayer c'est le cauchemar brésilien
qui lui publié aux éditions grâce et
voilà merci encore une fois à tous
d'avoir participé à ce débat je vous dis
à demain pour un nouveau numéro de
sciences publiques vous pouvez retrouver
tous les programmes de la chaîne sur
notre plateforme public sénat.fr et puis
notez que Jean-Pierre Raffin l'ancien
Premier ministre sera l'invité Dorian
Mancini demain dans la matinale vers 8
heures du matin belle soirée
[Musique]